welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and spider-mans days in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe maybe sadly over over
well for now at least
due to talks reportedly breaking down
between Sony the studio that owns the
film rights of spider-man and Disney's
Marvel Studios Kevin Feige wonderful
dream world that we all call the MCU
since 2015 Marvel and Sony have shared
the rights to spider-man but that deal
has according to sources ended and that
might mean we no longer get to see
spider-man appear in future MCU films
and that MCU characters no longer appear
in future spider-man movies yeah again
okay so I'm gonna explain what the hell
happened here and how this could
dramatically change the future of
superhero movies as we know them and
what this means for a spider-man 3 film
and why maybe just maybe all might not
be lost
ok so here's what went down back in 2015
Marvel and Sony announced a deal to
co-produce spider-man after Sony who had
owned the rights to spider-man for
decades decided to shift directions from
the two underperforming amazing
spider-man films with Andrew Garfield as
directed by Marc Webb the deal was
Marvel Studios and Sony share spider-man
so that Sony got to make spider-man
movies with Marvel characters like Tony
Stark
Nick Fury and Cu events like the blip
and that Marvel Studios got to feature
Peter Parker in their big crossover
events Civil War affinity war and war
and in all 5 of these movies Marvel head
Kevin Feige was the studio connective
tissue keeping the tonality and
interconnectivity in balance as all
things should be now the plan was to
extend this sharing deal by two more
films presumably a Spider Man 3 and
maybe another MCU crossover event so
what changed well according to Deadline
during negotiations between Disney and
Sony Disney asked for the next
spider-man movie and other Sony
properties that Disney wanted to code
distribute that the studio's co-financed
them 50/50 and that will mean the
studio's would also split the profits
from these films right down the middle
essentially Kevin Feige and the Disney
Marvel team wanted more influence over
Sony's properties and to reap more
reward for that influence
we'll keep helping you make Spidey but
you got to pay up for it I got new hats
to buy but Sony according to sources
flat-out refuse that offer and talks
broke down why well spider-man far from
home
just became Sony's most profitable film
of all time crossing a 1.1 billion
dollars of the box office in due to
general greed you can imagine them not
wanting to share a dime of any future
billions and it looks as though Sony is
betting that the recent success of the
spider-man character has perhaps less to
do with vikas magic touch and the
interconnectivity to the MCU
which in far from home spoiler warning
for that movie's vivid scene yeah took
the form of some Iron Man murals X stark
industry employees happy Hogan Nick Fury
Maria Hill and Skrulls instead perhaps
Sony is looking at elements like
Mysterio returning Jay jonah Jameson in
the groundwork that they've already done
to introduce these sinister six and back
to themselves maybe we don't need the
MCU connection to make a good spider-man
3 movie one that we wouldn't have to
share now I take issue with that but
based on the tremendous success of a
movie like spider-man into the spider
verse which won an Oscar I'm not
surprised Sony feels confident that
their spider-man properties are robust
enough to not need uncle fieger's to
hold their hand but I gotta say this
just feels like the wrong move fans have
really enjoyed the collaboration between
Sony and Marvel that has given us Tom
Hollands Peter Parker now I'm not sure
how much Kevin Feige and the Marvel team
were directly responsible for everything
we liked about this version of the
character it's possible that John Watson
Tom Holland could produce another great
Spider Man sequel without Marvel's help
but over these past four years Peter
Parker's also forged chemistry with a
number of MCU mainstays Doctor Strange -
the guardians of the galaxy Falcon and
Winter Soldier Rhodey ant-man Captain
Marvel Nick Fury
well his scroll and posture but still
Sam Jackson add that to future possible
team ups with characters like the Hulk
Thor and future MCU additions like blade
the Fantastic Four Wolverine the other
mutants maybe someday daredevil the
Human Torch in Deadpool State fans if I
do understand that it's the promise of
spider-man merely existing in this
universe hitchhiking on the back of
Valkyries Pegasus that makes them so
exciting it's awesome to know that
there's a kid who can just accidentally
swing into any bonkers situation react
the way we would react and know just the
right movie reference to take care of
business and Sony walking away from
Marvel here takes that promise and it
drowns it in sin biota
worst of all Sony's forcing happy Hogan
and Aunt May to breakup totally sucks
happy really needs us his name does not
reflect this emotional state now look
the MCU has plenty a beloved titles
besides spider-man and you could say
they'd probably braced for this
explaining why spider-man wasn't
included in Feige space for lineup but
spider-man remains the crowned jewel I
guess we were lucky to get him in the
MCU as long as we have and we're
grateful but you know now it's kind of
like the awesome dude that we've been
hanging out with is being told that he
can and with us anymore because his
parents don't like our parents and we
know he was a better version of himself
with his with us but guys guys this
isn't over
sources are saying negotiations are
still under way and it is possible that
this just got leaked to deadline is a
kind of power play by one of the sides
great public pressure to bring the other
side back to the table but here's what
Sony being willing to walk away from
Marvel tells us about their priorities
for future spider-man films I do not
think this means that Tom Holland is
automatically done playing spider-man
like if spider-man is in the title of a
movie folks the actors and crew of that
movie signed a deal with Sony not Disney
so it's possible that the studio the
director the other key players could put
together a Sony produced spider-man 3
that everyone's happy with and it could
happen it's also possible that this
increases the likelihood of a venom
sequel with Tom Hollands spider-man I
don't know how I feel about that
whatever you feel about the Tom Hardy
venom if this were to happen it would
require a great deal of tonal
adjustments like essentially Sony would
have to do with Tom Hardy's venom what
Marvel did with Thor in Ragnarok like
transform him from a moody loner to
funnier team player another option would
be to build on the success of into the
spider-verse
live action spider people like Miles
Morales for Gwen Stacy like if Sony is
robbing us of Peter Parker Hangouts with
the Hulk or Deadpool they got to be
counting on their ability to please fans
with other beloved names from the comics
but really the most likely option just
seems to be a Spider Man 3 that deals
directly with the aftermath of the PAR
from home post credits scene and perhaps
he's sinister 6 that has to ignore any
of the ties to the MCU from homecoming
or far from home like Peter would have
to off-screen sever all of his
connections to Tony Stark probably toss
out Edith and all this uniquely stark
tech and then like web all over all the
spider-man murals and then force Aunt
May to break up with happy but I guess
if all the familiar faces return Plus J
jonah Jameson and a sinister six maybe a
lot of fans wouldn't
I mean we would cuz rolled her and we
remember how great things were in the
past but a dopey little eight-year-old
who's gonna buy all the toys he's gonna
be like oh great spider-man this is the
only spider-man movie that ever existed
essentially Sony is like Panos telling
Feige I will shred your universe down to
its last atom and then with the work
you've done for me create my own
grateful universe that doesn't remember
your old one yeah no wonder Sony doesn't
want spider-man and panis in the same
sentence do you think there's a future
for Tom Hollands spider-man outside the
MCU hit me up down in the comments this
is a hard time for us but we're here for
each other right follow me unser Girma
Twitter Eddie Ava subscribe to new rock
sirs for more Morrow updates is
something changed about the situation we
will inform you and break it down for
you thank you for joining me and I just
don't want to be there when happy gets
dumped I guess it's just gonna be a loan
with Tony's claw robot because that's
not the worst way to spend a Friday
night
[Music]